Hi, I'm John Green, this is Crash Course
English Literature, and today we return to
Romeo and Juliet, a tale of love and woe.
Or else a tale of lust and woe.
Anyway, it's definitely a tale of woe.
As the play begins, Romeo is telling us that
he is completely in love with a girl, and will never love anybody else, and her name is Rosaline.
And a day later - A SINGLE DAY –
he has married an entirely different girl!
And the whole thing is forbidden in a desperate and exciting way –
"My only love sprung from
my only hate", etc.
And that makes me wonder, does romantic
love benefit from – or maybe even require – these
kinds of obstacles to feel intense and real?
Mr. Green, Mr. Green! Yes.
Truly spoken like a teenager, Me from the Past,
because from where I'm sitting, true love is when
you're standing in line at a Chipotle, and you say,
"I shouldn't get guacamole", and the great love of
your life says, "You know what? Just get the guac!"
And then you go home, and you watch TV
together while eating burritos.
THAT's true love, Me from the Past, of a depth
and quality that you can only imagine and poor
Romeo and Juliet will never know.
And not least because there were no
Chipotles in medieval Verona.
[Theme Music]
So it's telling to look at the way that Juliet describes
her own feelings and the reasons for them.
She calls their romance:
"too rash, too unadvised, too sudden;
Too like the lightning, which doth cease to be
Ere one can say 'It lightens.'"
But then in the same scene, she says:
"My bounty is as boundless as the sea,
My love as deep; the more I give to thee,
The more I have, for both are infinite."
The lightning is over in a flash, but the
sea is infinite. Juliet also famously speaks
of her "true love's passion", which conflates
two very different ideas. As previously noted,
true love is eating burritos together on the
couch in your sweatpants, whereas passion
never involves burritos. - what's that? What's
Rule 34? Oh? Rea- Wow. Really? Okay, yes,
apparently passion occasionally involves burritos.
By the way, this play is full of bawdy jokes,
usually told in prose, courtesy of the Nurse
or Mercutio, so it's not like Shakespeare
wasn't aware of sex without love. Are Romeo
and Juliet making themselves believe
they're in love to excuse their sexual desire?
Would Juliet have gotten tired of Romeo? Stan, I
thought that we had established that these
were real. How is this... why is this happening... ah,
it's a metaphor, isn't it, Stan? Get rid of the metaphor.
Possibly, Romeo can be a little bit intense,
like sword-fight-murder intense. And although
Juliet violently rejects Paris, the man her
father wants her to marry, he seems like a
pretty stand-up guy, and in many ways, is
a better match for her than Romeo.
So Romeo and Juliet's flirtation follows the
traditions of courtly love, a medieval concept
still popular in the Renaissance, that advocates
love at first sight, and forswearing all for love.
But vitally, you aren't supposed to sully
courtly love with sex or marriage, and Romeo
and Juliet clearly do. You're supposed to
sit around and pine and be miserable for the
rest of your Edith Wharton-ing life, like
Petrarch and Dante did, all these supposedly
amorous Italians, but all they ever did was
write poems.
Right, so you could really read the first
couple of acts of Romeo and Juliet as a potential
comedy - girl falls for the wrong boy, they've
got to figure out what to do. So far, that's
the plot of A Midsummer Night's Dream. But
with those characters, there was no skoodilypooping.
Romeo and Juliet do skoodilypoop, and sullying
their love with sex, even post-marital sex,
proves kind of deadly. Oh, it's time for the
Open Letter?
An open letter to literary sex. But first, let's
see what's in the secret compartment today.
Oh, it's Shakespeare socks! Perfect, because Stan won't let me wear shoes, because they just painted the set.
Dear literary sex, why you gotta be so fatal?
Here's an interesting fact - until about 40
years ago, every single human who was ever
born, was born as a result of sex. But to
read the great novels and plays of human history,
you would think that the mere act of having
sex is fatal, like 65% of the time. How did
we acquire all these Montagues and Capulets
if just having sex is so dangerous?
And I've noticed that having sex is particularly
fatal to young ladies. And that doesn't seem
very fair! After all, it does take two, to
fandango.
Best Wishes,
John Green.
Okay, but as always in Shakespeare, it's not
quite that simple, and there are indications
that Romeo and Juliet may be, at least in
Shakespeare's conception, really in love.
I mean, in their first conversation, they
speak a total of fourteen lines to each other,
and those fourteen lines, when combined, form
a perfect Shakespearean sonnet. So this isn't
some random hook-up at a party; this is literally
instant poetry. And Shakespeare bestows some
of his most gorgeous lines of them - Northrop
Frye called this play "word magic".
Not only that, but remember, through their
deaths, this intractable conflict between
two families is ended. And in that story of
transcendental suffering and sacrifice, one
can't help but recall the more famous story of
transcendental suffering and sacrifice -- that of Jesus.
So Romeo and Juliet don't really do much together
- if you think about it, they don't even actually
die together. Only a few days separate their
meeting and their deaths.
We can see the play, then, as a tragedy about
time - how little there is of it - and also
about about youth - how we assign passionate
importance to things and people when we're
young, because we don't have the breadth of
experience to behave more moderately. Which
is maybe the tragedy of adulthood. Old folks, Juliet maintains, are "unwieldy, slow, heavy and pale as lead."
But for me, the play is ultimately about having
to make difficult choices with limited information.
This love, which feels real, and therefore,
I would argue, is real, has to be balanced
against responsibilities to your family, and to the state,
in the form of the Prince of Verona, and to the Church.
In your life, are you going to seek what you
want, or are you going to listen to your parents
when they tell you what to want, or to the
state, when it tells you what to want? Until
the end of the play, both Romeo and Juliet
are trying to find ways to please all these
masters - the self, the state, the church,
the family - and that is what kills them.
Had they just run away together, or hooked
up without getting married, in an un-churchly
fashion, they probably would have survived.
Their love is an ardent and over-the-top response
to the violent and unjust world in which they
live, and the patriarchal authority that controls
that world. But they can never fully abandon
or reject that authority. And this is still
a challenge for teenagers, who are often dismissed
as idealistic or melodramatic, and who must
balance the intensity of their feeling against
the expectations of the world around them.
Don't drop out of high school to follow your
dream of being a trapeze artist, honor thy
father and mother, register for the draft,
don't pass up a full ride to Harvard to follow
your girlfriend into the Marines, etc. Let's
go to the Thought Bubble.
As Harley Granville-Barker puts it, "Romeo
and Juliet is a tragedy of youth as youth
sees it." If you're young or have ever been
young, you know what it's like to be pulled
in many directions while trying to discern
whether feelings that are brand-new to you
are more like "flashes of lightning" or an
"eternal ocean". And you know what it's like
to want to live fully and fearlessly, and
maybe even a little foolishly. And the occasionally
tragic thing is that you are just grown-up enough,
for that kind of thinking to get you killed.
Romeo and Juliet, to live the lives they want,
must also alter the world, or maybe even the
cosmos. They're always looking for night to
come quickly, or to stay late -- Juliet tells
the horses that draw the sun to "Gallop apace,
you fiery-footed steeds", a speech that was
considered so racy that many nineteenth-century
actresses wouldn't perform it.
And in the next scene, after their single
night of wedded bliss,
she tries to keep the dawn from arriving,
telling Romeo: "...it is not yet near day:
It was the nightingale, and not the lark,
That pierced the fearful hollow of thine ear..."
Characters are constantly evoking light and
dark imagery, and calling out to the sun and
the moon, to day and night, as if they were
seeking some control over the universe. Because
it's they only way they can have all of what
they want - their families at peace, their
faith, and their life together in their hometown.
But the universe will not bend to them, or
to anyone -- no matter how real your love,
you can't avoid fate, and you can't alter time. Well,
except for daylight savings. Thanks, Thought Bubble.
So, that's one way to read the story - Romeo
and Juliet's hubris in believing they could
change the universe leads to their demise.
But actually, how responsible are they?
I mean, there's a lot of bad luck involved.
There's the messenger's delay, the hastening
of the wedding between Juliet and Paris...
Now, in the source material, Brooke's "The
Tragic History of Romeus and Juliet," Brooke
makes it explicit that it's their own fault,
and they get what they deserve. But Shakespeare
is a lot more ambivalent -- the friar who marries
them worries that "violent delights have violent ends,"
which seems to imply that Romeo and
Juliet are to blame for their own undoing.
But the play calls them "star-crossed," which
implies that their sad end was written out
by fate, before they ever even met.
As with so much Shakespeare, and with great
literature in general, how you feel about
this question says a lot about you. And these
meditations on faith, combined with the question
of whether immediate attraction can lead to lasting love, have made Romeo and Juliet a story with legs.
These days, it might be race that separates
the two loves, as in West Side Story, or religion,
as in a 90's production in Bosnia that saw
a Christian Romeo and a Muslim Juliet.
The obstacles may change, but the underlying problem
of love in an unjust world isn't going anywhere.
It's tempting to dismiss the plot of Romeo
and Juliet as sappy, emo romance, but in truth,
each of us will live out our lives having
answered, consciously or not, the questions
at the heart of the play. Do you believe that
fate is inescapable, or that people forage
their own lives? Is the fault in the stars,
or in ourselves? And will you prioritize your
personal wishes, or the wishes of your family,
or your religion, or your country?
If you think about it, Romeo and Juliet aren't
offered an easy choice. They could hurt family
members they love, or they can hurt each other.
Either way, there will be tragedy, and these
messy, ambiguous, ethically fraught high-stakes
questions are still a part of all of our lives.
Shakespeare's gift to us is giving a voice
to them, in all their maddening complexity.
Thanks for watching. I'll see you next time.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller, our script supervisor is Meredith
Danko, the associate producer is Danica Johnson,
the show is written by Alexis Siloski and
myself, and our graphics team is Thought Bubble.
Instead of cursing, I use the names of writers
I like. If you want to suggest future writers,
you can do so in comments, where you can also
ask questions about today's video that will
be answered by our team of highly-trained
English-y people!
Thanks for watching Crash Course, and as I
often say, while sitting upon my golden throne,
Don't Forget To Be Awesome.